على كل ينضم لنا في الاستديو الفنان باسل
الخياط يسعد صباحك باسل نورتنا في
الاستديو شكرا تواجدك معانا
من الصبح صباح الخير صباح الخير لكم ولكن
اللي عم يشوفونا وان شاء الله دائما
ايامكم خير يا رب
بالنجاح حافله بالاعمال الدراميه سينمائيه
حديثنا اكثر عن باسل لكل المحبين لكم
معجبينك
انا باسل قاعد جنبكم يعني واا
بحبها جدا
وجدي بعملي هيك كنت بتهموني يعني انه جدي
بيعمل زياده عن اللزوم
خلاص التصوير مسلسل التمام يعني صار لي
فتره لابس فيها ما عملت يعني كنت بعيد عن
المسلسلات الطويله بس هي سنه ان شاء الله
راح نطلع على جمهور بمسلسل طويل شويه يعني
ان شاء الله ما نكون يعني تقال عليهم
مسلسل رح يكون طويل من 90 حلقه بس ان شاء
الله بتحبوه ان شاء الله
الثمن اكيد امبارح للسكن بهذا الموضوع
اكيد كل شيء بالحياه له ثمن
انا شخصيا بشوف انه الحياه ما بتعطيكي كل
شيء بتعطيك من طرف تاخذ من طرف ثاني صح
بالنسبه للثمن هو ال يعني هو يمكن رد
الفعل اللي ممكن يصير بالنسبه
[موسيقى]
للحياه للطاقه الجمعيه اللي ممكن تصير
لحتى الواحد دائما يكون في اكشن وفي اكشن
بالنسبه لنا بمسلسل الثمن يعني كله هيدفع
الثمن احنا عندنا هيك شيء بنقول بالمسلسل
كله هيدفع الثمن يعني كله هيدفع الثمن
شوف مقطع منه المشاهدين ونرجع نسالك عنه
اوكي
[موسيقى]
كل واحد هيدفع الثمن
طيب باسل شفنا مقطع من الثمن تحديات
لواجهتموها 90 حلقه صورتوه في سبعه اشهر
مسلسل
يعني هذا النوع من المسلسلات بياخذ وقت
لانه هذا انا اللي بالصوره
ههه هذا انا ولا مين
ههه
فكرت يعني الميك اب كان يعني عامل ميك اب
انا من المسلسل الدرجه يعني ايه فالمسلسل
همم طويل همم 90 حلقه مثل ما قلت لكم قبل
شوي هذا تانجو اوكي
بالحب ممكن تعطينا هندسه
[موسيقى]
بس خليني اكمل سالتيني على الاجواء كانت
همم
ممتعه وصعبه بنفس الوقت لانه عم بشتغل في
مكان لسه جديده علينا كلياتنا بس الحقيقه
كان في جو كثير حلو كان عم يقوده المخرج
فكره القاضي وجوله تحيه همم فكنا الحقيقه
مستمتعين ولو انه كان يعني كان في شويه
ظروف صعبه كونه كل شيء جديد علينا بالنسبه
انا بقول المسلسل يعني زين شخصيتي اسمها
زين هو همم
هذا شيء يعني سلبي بالنسبه لشخص انه لا
يثق همم ما عنده ثقه في المراه بشكل عام
ما عنده ثقه في الجنس الاخر نتيجه همم
اشياء صارت معه بحياته فهو عنده رده فعل
همم
بشكل عام بشوف انه لا يؤمن بالحب مع الجنس
الاخر بيشوف انه همم الحب مرتبط بالنسبه
لهم بمشروع ممكن من خلاله همم
عنده زلمه خاف من هذا الموضوع بيخاف من
الحب يعني شو رايكم انتم بالموضوع
ثقه بالطرف الثاني وبس اللي عنده ثقه بطرف
الثاني
بشكل كثير كبير
همم ما فيني اقول لك انه همم تفضل شيء عن
شيء وانما في بعض الشخصيات بتاخذ عمل وجهد
اكثر يعني مثلا بهذه السنه بمنعطف خطر
كان فيها جهد ولكن كانت اسهل من شخصيات
ثانيه عملتها يعني مثلا منعطف خطر اللي
عملته قبل قبل هذا المسلسل ونعرض على شاهد
كان من اصعب الشخصيات اللي عملتها في
مسلسل اسمه الرحله عملته بمصر همم في
الكاتب كتير بحبه هذا المسلسل وكمان شخصيه
لعبه شخصيه اشتغل فيها على
محقق هو ساخر محقق ساخر بتعامل مع الحياه
بسخريه تامه فكان فكره ال- ال- العمل
بالنسبه الي مع المخرج رامي احنا انه نطلع
نوعا شخصيه
عموما من الاطار همم خلينا لك ال همم
مسلسلات
مثل ما قلت قبل شوي بقول انه هذا المسلسل
الناس في تعبئه جدا عندنا وقت كثير طويل
بذلنا جهد كتير كتير مسلسل
بعتقد انه هو قريب من الناس
دراما بسيطه من النوع السهل البسيط ولكن
المؤثر عن نناقش في عده قضايا تنطلق من
علاقه رومانسيه بين رجل وامراه شروط الحب
بيناتهم او شروط العلاقه غير مكتمله فعملش
تداعيات هذه اعتاد انه
هذا النوع من المسلسلات او هذه خليني اقول
لك همم نوعيه الاعمى الاعمال همم بتلاقي
احسان استحسان بالنسبه للجمهور بهاي
الفتره خصوصا انه كل حياتنا بشكل او باخر
يعني همم نعشق الحب من حب الحب همم وكل
واحد عنده الاكسبيرينس تبعه وعنده ذاكرته
احساس اكثر من ما هي مكتوبه في اوقات شعر
بس لانه بده يطلع عن النص والي مكتوب
والله ناخذ المخرج معينه انا يمكن اول مره
بحكيها بشكل
واضح انا دائما بطلع على النص يعني ما
بقدر من لما كنت اصلا طالب في المعهد وحتى
الان ما بقدر ما فيني يلتزم همم دائما
باحس انه يعني انا وانتوا هلا قاعدين بهذا
المكان اوكي احنا عندنا عنوان لشيء بدنا
نحكي فيه ولكن ما بنعرف اوكي فانا باحب
دائما بعملي انه تحديدا في ما يتعلق
بالحوار
بنسبه كثير كبيره لما بلشت الى الان ما
بقدر التزم بالحوار
الثمن مين الممثل اللي كان اقرب لباسل في
هذا العمل والله يعني الكل الحقيقه جمعتني
فيهن علاقه يعني سبع شهور قاعدين مع بعض
صرنا مثل عيله كبيره الحقيقه يعني كلياتنا
مع بعض
الكل الكل يعني كنت سعيد جدا بالعمل مع
الاستاذ الصباح جزائري بتجنن مع نيكولا مع
مع رزان مع طلال مارديني مع الاستاذ رفيع
علي احمد الحقيقه مع الكل مع ساره مع ريان
تحيه لهم كلهم
ان شاء الله يا رب يعني بيقدروا يحسدوا
منه
عشان لما نحكي عن مسلسل بس حلقاته طويله
اليوم صار في توجهات الحلقات المسلسلات
القصيره كيف مسلسل كاتبته
المسلسلات القصيره
العمل
انا بشخصيه تمتد على مدى 90 حلقه اكيد بده
يكون الجهد موزع على 90 حلقه غير لما يكون
انت في عندك مسلسل من سبعه حلقات
طبعا مختلفه
عن هذا المسلسل يرجع يتفرج يحس انه هو مضى
عليه فهذا النوع اله شروطه واللي هي
احيانا بتكون قاسيه
انا بس
هو نوع
ليش لا يعني
واثبت التجربه انه هذا النوع عم يحبوه
الناس
من ضمن المسلسل شكرا